hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Sammy and Jack Black
and we're here to promote the new movie
that's coming out October 16th
goosebumps
that's right and to do that we're gonna
play five minutes to 34 cool first of
all I'd like to say it nice to meet you
mr. applier nice to meet you mr. Jack
Black I was working on that joke for a
while thank you nice to meet you too
soon
that's me you ready to play okay cool go
ahead I know that's so weird the way his
eyes cracked but you stay up there so
sad cuz he curls into a ball tomorrow
the graphics got way better yeah exactly
we move forward a few years ago
technology what a difference a day makes
so right over there that reminds me of
the phone guy doesn't yeah and then it's
there's a purple robot and fan again and
it reminds me of like that kind of means
a you're way more observant than
I have observant ofthe and I ever was
because I didn't notice those from I
observe a kid thank you I mean you're
the natural vocabulary test and I'm not
that's right I play or else coming in
goose bumps October 16 it's coming out
and do this for October 16
now it's actually weird because when I
when I saw the trailer I've never
actually seen
Aurel Stein in a person but I definitely
got like vibes of Stephen King yeah
they're playing it is there like any of
that that leak through Darla Stein for
that yeah well there's a running joke in
the movie that there's a rivalry between
RL Stein and Stephen King yeah that you
know RL Stein is actually like super
jealous of Stephen King yeah
which isn't actually true actually
they're friends let's have three am so
things start happening
hey you ever met Scott Scott no not in
person he's he's in a family man with
two kids but he works very much alone
than by himself how do you know he's a
family man with two kids is it possible
that really you're Scott hey I always
listened for that breathing cuz I'll put
it on if you want me to put it off you
never know
it's not a kitchen oh you've been lucky
I died five times on this first night I
think you might actually I know yeah
you're doing great
wait uh oh famous last words
that's what you do with greater go to
the left one now you haven't took the
levels oh no you made bro
I died five times the first time that
[Music]
theme song that is similar to your old
one I'm available it's all right are you
were you family this bumps grown-up like
I don't know what it is I came late to
the game
I didn't start reading the books until
after I read the screenplay I read the
screenplay really yeah I didn't I didn't
I wasn't even aware that there was this
this huge phenomenon known as the the
goosebumps Francesca what were you you
know about oh yeah as a kid I read a
bunch of the books I don't remember a
lot of but I honestly read the choose
your own adventure books oh me too my
jam I love that I read all of those are
you okay you didn't listen for the
breathing
yeah yeah he was doing great I deserve a
jump-scare because this is not control
[Laughter]
[Music]
my chances oh you're gonna die
you got I was like do I hear breathing I
think I do
and then we instantly die I deserved
that so Jack what was it like filming
the movie okay you ready ready
we had a blast making the movie we shot
it all in it land to jaja really yeah
that's where we found the spookiest old
houses cool apparently that's just where
they had the spookiest of architectures
I'm just gonna leave it like this get
over here
Sammy why are you trying to I've had a
lot of fun here today with you I think
we was shared a lot we learned a lot
about me and my movie goosebumps yes I
didn't learn a lot about you oh I
thought I was pretty selfish I made it
all about me but I made something for
you yeah I made you a paper plane here
give it to him salmon well you can just
throw it towards him hey yeah that's
what they're for they're for throwing I
had fun and also
I didn't know what I didn't even know we
got you a little something thank you for
making this for me you grew these yeah
wait Wow made you have played it fruit
ooh those name our garden they're good
great
bye everybody
hi hey we're just moving in you see that
fence I see on your side of it he's a
big teddy bear don't take it personally
it doesn't really like anyone
yeah Hannah's in trouble Oh who's Hannah